it is no secret that i have been a major
tesla fanboy ever since i first drove
their model s way back in 2014. they had
just introduced the ludicrous mode and i
was blown away by the jaw-dropping
acceleration of that car i mean 0-60 in
under 3 seconds and that too in an
all-electric car for a petrol head like
myself it was almost a spiritual
experience i was convinced on that day
that tesla would become the most
groundbreaking car company in america
and perhaps the entire world and looking
at tesla's growth since that time i
wasn't wrong at all until i drove the
new kid on the block earlier this month
if you read the title of this video i
guess you already know which car i am
referring to here it is the lucid motors
lucid air a friend of mine had just got
the delivery of one of the first lucid
air dream edition and he invited me over
to test it out now mind you i had seen a
lot of pictures of the new car heard a
lot about its performance pedigree and
also seen reviews from auto gurus who
had test driven the vehicle before its
launch but nothing would compare to what
i was going to experience in the next
few minutes of actually driving the car
first on the highways and then in anger
around a local karting track it was at
the end of that day that a thought crept
into my head that people at tesla should
be afraid of this new beast of an
electric vehicle so in this video for
simply tech i am going to share with you
my experience with the lucid air and why
i think tesla should stand up and take
notice of this nissan car brand and its
amazing first model before i get into
why i feel the way i feel about this car
let's set the stage a bit and go over
some of the specifics of this new car
and the company responsible for its
development lucid motors is by no means
a new company it was founded way back in
2007 but it was called ativa until 2016
when it was rebranded as lucid motors
the company in its early days was mostly
focused on manufacturing batteries and
powertrains for other electric vehicle
manufacturers then in 2013 and 2015 two
key personnel changes would see this
small california headquartered company
change dramatically into a full-fledged
electric vehicle manufacturer the first
was peter rawlinson who joined the
company in 2013 as his chief technology
officer before he took this position
rollinson served as the vice president
of vehicle engineering responsible for
the development and delivery of the
first tesla model s the second key
personnel change was the addition of
derek jenkins from the mazda mx-5 hall
of fame jenkins was the head of design
for mazda and joined lucid motors as the
senior vice president of design and
brand in 2015. both these guys would
take the company out of obscurity and by
late 2016 they had rebranded and
announced the development of lucid's
first production all-electric car the
lucid air now you must be thinking
that's all well and good but what's so
good about the car that tesla which is a
giant in the all-electric segment
producing over 200 000 vehicles per year
have to fear well let's take a look at
the specifics then the lucid air is a
full-size luxury sedan that has been
designed from the ground up as an
all-electric vehicle and it shows it has
an epa range of up to 520 miles on a
single charge and can do zero to 60
miles per hour in just under two and a
half seconds but those are just numbers
and even cheap chinese electric car
manufacturers can make an electric car
with those specs on paper no what
separates lucid air and why a giant like
tesla should take notice is what's
inside the car the technological
innovations driving the performance of
the car are staggering in some regards
for example the lucid air claims to be
40 percent more efficient than any other
electric car on the road today in fact
it can travel 17 further than a tesla
model s long range for the same battery
pack size this is because lucid has
managed to improve the efficiency of its
battery pack by working on its layout
and cooling systems within it has
allowed them to extract 4.6 miles per
kilowatt hour which is 15 more efficient
than the tesla model s long range which
has a similar battery size and guess
what that is not even the crazy part the
battery in the lucid air is based around
the formula e race car a global
championship where lucid motor has been
the primary battery supplier since 2018.
rapid development through racing has
allowed lucid motors to shrink the size
of the battery pack and make it more
efficient without sacrificing any safety
or range this racing pedigree is
reflected even better when it comes to
the power train of the car officially
called the pure flux inverter and
transmission unit this is at the heart
of lucid air's sublime performance and
driving experience this is a vertically
arranged powertrain that weighs only 163
pounds but it can deliver 670 horsepower
at 4 400 pounds per foot of torque that
is getting in the range of performance
dragsters and we are talking about a
four-door luxury all-electric sedan here
it can do this because of its permanent
magnet synchronous motors which can spin
it up to 20 000 rpm on both the front
and the rear of the vehicle this
prevents a phenomenon called torque
clogging giving the powertrain more
performance the air's dream performance
edition has a dual configuration of
these motors that can deliver a whopping
111 horsepower that is getting in the
leagues of a formula one car although
the f1 car is way more powerful due to
its low weight this version of the car
can cover a quarter of a mile in 9.8
seconds which absolutely blows my mind
to be honest i have driven almost all
models of tesla cars in tracks and
pretty diverse conditions but never have
i felt such confidence throwing a car
around corners or when flooring the
pedal to the floor due to the weight
distribution of the battery pack and the
drivetrain the air is extremely stable
on its feet even when i was barrel
rolling the lucid air around a race
track at high speeds there was never a
moment where i felt like i was going to
lose control i mean from the
driver-focused comfortable cockpit to
the four-corner suspension system the
air's handling characteristics felt
deserving of its name at this point most
of you guys are wondering well tesla has
a lot of smart features and that is
surely a segment where they are way
ahead of the curve but you would be
wrong thinking that as well lucid air
features a dream drive advanced driver
assistance system that integrates 32
sensors from cameras to ultrasonic
sensors to high-res lidar placed
strategically all over the car
performing various smart autonomous
functions although lucid has not
announced anything like tesla's dojo
chip or its advanced neural net program
which is designed to make the car fully
self-driven i won't be surprised if they
are also planning something similar in
nature for the future you don't put this
many sensors around a car if you didn't
want to leave room to grow and develop
on top of all these features the design
of the air is also quite elegant and
apparently the aerodynamics have been
given extra focus this has allowed the
designers of lucid motors to extract 2
percent more performance just by
sculpting the bodywork to reduce excess
drag this just goes to show how much the
company is driven by efficiency no
wonder then that the company has already
made waves in the automotive industry
and i can confidently say that after
having driven my friends air a few more
times after that first test there is
nothing in the car that i don't like i
mean it can even add range at the rate
of 300 miles per 30 minutes of charging
plus its two-way multifunctional booster
charger the wonderbox is also capable of
vehicle to vehicle charging essentially
allowing you to use your car as a giant
backup battery lucid motors went public
in early 2021 at a valuation of 24
billion dollars within a few months its
valuation blew past general motors 65
billion dollars and then ford's 85
billion dollars it is now one of the
most highly valued car manufacturers in
the u.s and with over 25 000 orders in
2022 which is expected to double next
year it is also fast growing if
rawlinson and jenkins keep delivering on
their promises then i can definitely see
it becoming a major rival of tesla not
only in the domestic u.s market but also
globally within the next five years if i
can draw this conclusion then i am sure
that elon and tesla must have imagined
this scenario as well and if so they
should definitely stand up and take this
challenge posed by lucid air seriously
that's all from my end today i hope all
of you watching get a chance to try out
this awesome electric car yourself and
if you already have do you agree that
tesla should fear lucid air drop a
comment i'd love to know what you guys
think